Speaker 1: This is this is kind of funny.
Fox News and other right wing media have gone
silent on ivermectin. One of the popular promoted
quote treatments for COVID that many on the right
wing media have promoted instead of vaccination
have promoted as a reason why we don't really
need to take precautions very early before there
was any evidence, they said. Ivermectin works,
and now that we have multiple studies that shows
ivermectin doesn't work for COVID, for COVID, some
people miss that. They go David. It works fine
for horse deworming or for parasitic infections.
Does it work for COVID? No. Fox News hasn't
issued an apology. As far as I know, Rogen and
others haven't issued apologies. They just aren't
talking about ivermectin anymore. So let's go back
a little bit early in the pandemic. I was right
there in the forefront. I think it was it was
March of 2020, if not April of 2020. And I came
to you and I said, Hey, here is a bunch of stuff
that is being looked at and it should be looked
at. There's this thing called hydroxychloroquine
should be looked at. It's being tested. There is
azithromycin. Does it have a possible antiviral
effect? It's going to be studied. We should
study it. A combination of I believe it was HIV
drugs that were being looked at. What about
taking the Z pack with zinc or with vitamin D?
And I said to you, there's eight to 12 different
things. We don't know. If they work for COVID,
they should be studied. They are being studied
and different right wing media fixated on one or
two of them and said, This just works. We have
a treatment. This works open everything. Early,
they fixated on hydroxychloroquine. Eventually,
it became a focus on ivermectin. Today, we know
ivermectin doesn't work for COVID. Right wing
media touted it for months and months and months.
They were convinced that it works, convinced
that there was a cover up because it's cheap
and they don't want you to. They don't want you
to know they used ivermectin promotion to cast
doubt on the vaccine while pushing something
unproven. You even had people saying the
vaccine is deadly. Alex Berenson said it, Tucker
Carlson said on his show. It seems that thousands,
tens of thousands of people may have died from
the vaccine. I mean, really crazy, dangerous stuff
while promoting ivermectin and claiming they don't
want you to know about it and they don't want you
to have it. We now know it doesn't work, OK? And
yet, Fox hosts pushed anecdote, anecdote after
anecdote, after anecdote. In fact, media aide has
a great sample of them. In January of last year,
Laura Ingraham said a friend of hers
took ivermectin after getting COVID,
and she got better. Now, what's the problem
with that? It's the same problem that exists
with a lot of homeopathic treatments, which is a
lot of things get better without doing anything,
for example, headaches. Wow. You know, I had a
terrible headache and then I ate a papaya with
peanut butter, and the next day I felt better.
Well, yeah, most people's headaches get better.
And it's the same thing with COVID. Most people
get better from COVID. I could say, you know,
I I had COVID and I decided to burn a bunch
of tennis balls, sprinkle cinnamon on it and
breathe the fumes. And within five days, I was
better of COVID. This is not how we study stuff,
particularly when you expect a regression to the
mean you, you expect that most people are going
to get better. OK. In September, Brian Kilmeade
suggested ivermectin could treat COVID, saying
Sometimes drugs work for different things. Yeah,
off-label uses are a thing. There was just no
evidence ivermectin works for COVID. In December,
Ben Carson said ivermectin is effective against
COVID. There was no such evidence. Two weeks
later, Tucker Carlson interviewed a psychiatrist
who said ivermectin could be a lifesaver. Now
my dad's a psychiatrist. He would not go around
telling you what works to treat COVID,
because that's not his area of expertize.
There were 300 or so such instances, but now
we have the data from actual studies. We have
a study called Efficacy of Ivermectin Treatment
on disease progression among adults with mild
to moderate COVID 19 and co-morbidities. And Kobe
doesn't work. I'm sorry. Ivermectin doesn't work
for COVID. I wish COVID didn't work. Ivermectin
doesn't work for COVID. And now Fox News and
other right wing media are silent. It's just not
a topic anymore. Like, they've talked about it
three hundred times, and I don't have any clips to
show you because there are no clips. They're not
talking about it anymore. It's like they always
do it. They just go silent. This actually happened
with hydroxychloroquine. Just think back. We did
a clip in April of 2020 called Trump and Fox go
silent on hydroxychloroquine because studies
came out after a month of talking about hydroxy,
saying it doesn't work for COVID. So then
they just never talked about it again.
Another example February Fox goes silent moment
after massive jobs report, they promoted and
predicted a bad jobs report four days up until the
jobs report came out. The jobs report was good.
Joe Biden's president. We don't talk about
it anymore, the media literacy takeaway here.
So there's there's like a COVID take away,
which is the ivermectin doesn't work. We now
know that great. There's a media literacy
away as well, which is the power of what
you don't talk about. This is the power of story
selection and power of the exclusion of stories.
I'm not immune to this. Like, I'll give you
an example. People email me. They say, David,
why aren't you talking about Hunter Biden? Hunter
Biden's laptop? That's right. I'm not. I don't
think it's a legitimate story to cover, and when
I talk about it, I talk about it to tell you,
look at how crazy the right is going about this.
But I'm not covering Hunter Biden's laptop story
as a story. I did it once I explained to you all
about the blind computer tech who thinks it might
be Hunter Biden's lap. You know this or that I
covered it once I told you what's being said,
but I do this too. I ignore some stories
because I don't think that they are stories.
Everybody does this. You just have to understand
whether it's being done in good faith or in bad
faith. And every time Fox News gets debunked
about whatever a jobs report, hydroxychloroquine,
ivermectin, you never hear about it again. Let me
know your thoughts. Find me on Twitter at Pacman
and next Tuesday, April 19th, we'll be doing the
next David Pakman Show Viewer Town Hall. It will
be at 6:00 Eastern and it will be streaming on
the Pacman Live YouTube channel. I want to hear
from as many of you as possible. That'll be
Tuesday, April 19th, 6:00 p.m. on the Pacman
Live YouTube channel. Quick break, right back.
The David Pakman Show is, of course, a viewer,
community listener supported program, we depend
on your support to do what we do five days a week
now. For many, many years, they tell me it's a big
number the folks do. You can sign up and support
us by getting a membership at Join Packman dot
com. You can also now gift memberships to others.
We have about 650 people who have requested a free
membership. We will fulfill those requests in the
order that people gift memberships. There is
a box that says this is a gift when you check
out at join Packman dot com and we will give out
those free memberships in the order that they come
in. You can, of course, always use the coupon code
woud to to discount your membership dramatically.
So much so that people are telling me that's too
big a discount, sir, and I insist they say no,
the people deserve it. The people deserve it.
Join Packman dot com is the place to sign up.